hello and welcome it's February 28 2023
it's active guest stream number 37.1 and
we're here with Baba Brinkman this
should be a great discussion an
emergence Baba thank you so much for
joining let's just jump right into it
what brings you to this day how and who
are you
and welcome
thanks thanks Daniel so much for having
me here it's a real uh it's a real honor
to join you and to uh you know dip into
this community which I've been aware of
for a while and uh you know like to try
to follow the work as much as I can but
I'm not a scientist myself uh I'm a
rapper I have been uh exploring academic
topics in hip-hop for quite a while I
did my Master's thesis on Chaucer's
Canterbury Tales I was a Renaissance and
medieval scholar uh and I I rewrote the
Canterbury Tales into rap and I used to
tour around the UK wrapping My Wife of
Bath's tail and Miller's tale Renditions
which was a lot of fun and then at one
point it was around 2007 or 2008 uh an
evolutionary biologist a geneticist saw
my Canterbury Tales show and he reached
out to me and said I love what you're
doing for medieval literature
popularizing and popularizing it with
rap but there's other topics that need
rap popularization I think his exact
words were would you be willing to do
for Darwin what you did for Chaucer and
this was a in the run-up to the uh the
Darwin Bicentennial in 2009 it was the
200th anniversary of uh the birth of
Charles Darwin also the 150th
anniversary of the publication of the
Origin of Species I was of course a big
fan of Darwin and of evolutionary theory
but not very expert so I said to this
scientist yes I'll write some raps about
Evolution but I could use some guidance
uh he sent me a whole bunch of suggested
reading sources books uh peer-reviewed
papers everything so I took a sort of
six month Deep dive on the state of
evolutionary theory uh absorbed a whole
bunch of books and uh and wrote These
Rhymes but his uh his his criteria was
your performances will be at academic
seminars with experts in darwinian
evolution across all kinds of social
domains and psychology and everything so
you need to make sure you represent the
theory accurately which means you have
to run your lyrics by me so I can check
them for scientific veracity uh which I
thought was a fair criteria for that
kind of context so I sent him my lyrics
he gave me some uh you know some
revision suggestions and then when I got
up when I was like set to perform the
premiere of my Darwin show in February
uh on Darwin day February 12 2009 uh the
scientist his name is Mark Palin he was
a bacterial geneticist he had this great
intro typical British tongue-in-cheek
style he was like I have fact check the
lyrics and you're about to witness the
first rap show in history that's peer
reviewed now like peer-reviewed rap
that's a great idea uh totally totally
marks coinage uh but then right away the
wheel started spinning like what other
topics could you apply the peer-reviewed
uh wrap lens to so I did my Evolution
rap show for several years it was called
the rap guide to Evolution it played Off
Broadway won an award at the Edinburgh
Fringe Festival and then other
scientists started tugging me on the
sleeve like oh the Darwin wraps are cool
but could you do
um Wilderness conservation and
threatened species ecology could you do
climate change could you do Neuroscience
uh and and various uh great
collaborations came from that so I now
have a whole series of rap albums rap
guides to various topics and my
encounter with the active inference uh
community and research base was when I
was working on one called the rap guide
to Consciousness and uh Professor Anil
Seth is one of the uh I think main
proponent opponents and contributors to
the Bayesian brain active inference
research Paradigm today and he was one
of the main science advisors on the
project so he was giving me Bayesian
stuff to read including Andy Clark's
what's next highly technical uh review
of all the literature which I slogged my
way through as a non-expert and ended up
working Bayesian ideas quite in a
detailed way into the rap guide to
Consciousness show and what really
resonated for me honestly I had never
really paid attention to Bayes theorem
or or Bayesian reasoning at all uh but I
you know it took me a while to get my
head around it but then I was like okay
this is actually just a great uh
paraphrase of the scientific method and
I was already a massive proponent of the
scientific method and I was geeking out
on the degree to which the brain may be
a Bayesian engine at the microscopic
level producing a rational inquiry
process that replicates the exact same
Bayesian algorithm at the level of
interactions with Society so I did one
song in the show called uh good Bayesian
let me show you how to be a good basy
and change your predictions after taking
information in and if you're thinking
I'll be less than amazing let's adjust
those expectations and I was right away
thinking about like how how is a rap
performance itself an instantiation of a
Bayesian algorithm with the audience's
expectations being revised in real time
based on the rapper's performance and
the rapper's expectations when creating
the script of the performance about what
reaction they'll get from the audience
which is a prior belief about the
effectiveness of the performance but
when it's only a script don't actually
know what's going to work and then you
do the performance you see what gets the
reaction you revise your priors and you
also revise your script and that was a
concept that I had already been rapping
about in my Evolution show I have a show
a whole song and that called performance
feedback revision which instantiates the
kind of evolutionary natural selection
algorithm but at the level of creative
writing and performance you write the
script you do the show you see how
people react you go back you change the
script and that's kind of like the
genome being revised under phenotypic
variants and how they end up Surviving
or not surviving reproducing or not
reproducing so
um you know this is I I just started out
rapping and trying to master the craft
and each scientific topic I get into I
start going oh this actually helps me
understand what's going on in rap much
better and especially actually one of
the examples I play with in the show
which is a lot of fun is like uh call-in
response expectations of the audience
like a perfect kind of demonstration
creation of a Bayesian moment when you
go
you know Double Take look twice
calculate the odds roll the and when I
do that the whole crowd would be like
dice you know but the expectation of
what the rhyme couplet's gonna be is a
game rappers play all the time like
finish the finish the bar right and that
is entirely around a setup of an
expectation and the Fulfillment of it
but then sometimes you can play with it
and be like yo perceptual Basics ask
Morpheus we live in the and I usually
get the crowd being like Matrix back of
me but then other times I'd make it more
difficult like yo perceptual basics
ladybugs like to eat and then like maybe
one person out of 100 would be like
aphids and I'd be like yeah you know
that that was the person that had the
correct scientific Bayesian prior is to
conclude my Matrix Basics aphids rhyme
pattern but usually only a few get it
and then everyone else is like ah
there's the nerd over there or whatever
so you know it's it's become like
actually informed my creative process in
terms of how I try to set up and violate
expectations in real time
psychologically with an audience when
I'm performing
um and I will be honest that my close
reading of the research was several
years ago at this point uh the rap guide
to Consciousness came out in 2017 uh 18
I was performing it Off Broadway 19 I
was uh touring it around uh theaters in
the UK and still performing Off-Broadway
and then 20 of course all performances
ceased all together and I had to think
about what rappers do in pandemics when
they can't get on stages and see crowds
so uh yeah we can talk uh during this
interview about my new project which is
a custom wrap agency you can see me
wrapping it right here event wrap uh
which could be fun to talk about in
terms of the event inference uh elements
of active inference and and Bayesian
analysis could be uh you know I think
some of the aspects of what attract me
to events What attracted me to events
during the pandemics and still does as a
sort of a catalyst for good art and for
rap might have to do with active
inference uh expectations and
experiences but I don't know this
literature very closely at this point so
um yeah that's basically brings us up to
the present hopefully that was a good
summary
amazing uh just great to
connect and to be able to share this
moment with someone who's seen it from
all sides
in front of the stage on stage behind
stage Inside the Mind real recognize
real
so there's a lot out there and just like
as if we were talking about a paper
namaste real recognize real namaste
if we were talking about a paper
we would read between the lines and
reference out and similarly there's so
much that can be referenced out and
people can listen to the original
creations and see what that primary text
looks like and the fact that it's uh
orally performed text for much of human
development in history was our real
so whether something is written
is increasingly fluid these days with
speech to text and text-to-speech so
there's going to be so many great
Avenues let's just start with
event-based cognition so what is an
event from the cognitive perspective
I mean I was trying to find that
definition with Google about 20 minutes
ago so I didn't sound like an idiot in
this podcast so uh I think it's a uh you
know a
it's a perceptual construct right it is
the perception of an entity that there
is some kind of instantiation of action
that is circumscribed in time that has a
beginning and an end and if it's not
perceived as having a beginning and an
end by some cognitive entity
historically organisms but in the future
also probably AIS uh then it's not you
know then it's not treated as an event
which means an event could be a thousand
years or five seconds or whatever it's
it's actually interesting how the kind
of the scientific definition of it in
active inference research really is like
a narrative definition in a way right
it's like it's like it's a story
something you can tell a story about
something you can construct a story
around uh is an event is that pretty
close to how scientists think about it
yeah I mean already so much there you're
right it does not have to be tied to a
given amount of clock time which we
might call chronology hearkening back to
Kronos that sort of decimal point time
but action takes place
in the understanding of the actor or the
observer in this time scale of action or
Kairos and that time scale of action
may be narrative and that is what you
invoke with the beginning middle and end
rising and falling cultural patterns
that's not necessarily happening on the
clock just because you can run a
stopwatch while somebody's reciting
Canterbury Tales
doesn't mean that
it'd be twice as exciting if they spoke
twice as fast or that you could
map in some linear way what was
happening on the watch face to what's
happening in the mind of audience who
have different familiarity with the
material or a historical study context
as well it just made me think of like if
I do a 10 minute long wrap of The Wife
of Bath's Tale then that's an event I
performed the wife of bathdale there was
an audience that witnessed it you could
circumscribe it that way but you could
also you know so you could do a
scientific study on what occurred during
that event right but you could also
choose to study the event of humanities
retelling of the story of The Wife of
Bath's tail which is a story that takes
place in King Arthur's Court so now we
know where the mythology has to have
started which is around you know forgive
me medievalists but let's say like four
or 500 A.D and then whenever the
historical King Arthur's Court existed
and then there was an oral mythology
that adhered to that over the course of
a period of time as people told folk
tales about it and then in the year 1400
uh Jeffrey Chaucer uh
well I think he perished in 1400 so he
was born in the 1330s but he writes the
wife of bath tale at some point as a
written representation of the oral
narrative and then that Vellum
manuscript is passed down into college
reading lists and I read it in 1998 and
write a rap version of it so any study
of Humanity's engagement with the story
of the wife of Bastille has to really
start uh you know in the year 400 and
and the last time I wrapped my rap
version of the wife of Bastille at the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival which was a
couple years ago and no event that
accounts for the phenomenon of the
telling of that story can leave any of
those instantiations out right
awesome it's like the earlier events are
our prior or our generative process
which is our Niche that events happen in
our generative model our cognitive model
exists within the niche the generative
process and those prior events quite
literally are our priors and there's no
last chapter because the observations
keep rolling in
and whether the observation is exactly
as expected whether that performance of
that symphony is exactly as expected but
they're that performance of the
hamburger or of the portrait
even if it's exactly as expected it
still is a new observation
and then what is as expected well that's
in the encultured cognitive mind and
that is this sometimes implicit
reference point that novelty is
contrasted against like well I knew I
was going to get a rap summary but I
didn't know it'd be that funny or I
didn't know I was going to get a rap
summary these are like different levels
and types of novelty about the story of
a moment or or look at how he changed
the story from the archival version
because there's definitely a completely
different experience of people that are
intimately familiar with trousers
version and ones who are hearing the
story for the first time and
encountering each of the story the
characters this is the kind of
expectation of how accurately will be
the story will the story be recounted in
this new version uh also let me just um
expand on something that you said he
said there's no last prior because
there's constant reinstantiations and
updating right but there is a last prior
from the perspective of a temporary
analysis of an event you can sort of you
can set a sort of artificial beginning
and end for the purpose of doing an
analysis and that's I guess where you're
able to apply mathematics to it but you
always have to like you know keep in
mind that it's a chosen beginning and
endpoint within a larger unfolding
yeah and that's very
um resonant with
my experience as a researcher which is
like there is a final data point in any
time series at some point the fmri
machine or the ant foraging watching
machine you just turn it off for the day
so there is empirically something that's
very addressable
but in the general case it's not the
case that a Time series algorithm
says what the last observation is and we
might even say that that's a
deflationary perspective on history
because rather than debating whether
somebody has released the definitive
American novel or the last word on this
Symphony it's like well the last note of
their Symphony was non-controversially
the last another Symphony but the
question about the discourse in the
community
of course there's no last word in this
open-ended space and art is always like
surfing on that open space
one of the things I remember from my uh
comparative literature courses is this
idea of the anxiety of influence and how
poets have their uh I think it's maybe
Harold Bloom that wrote that but it you
know poet poets have a sense of needing
to create something new I think it's
General like applies to Art all artists
right theater rappers you know you know
this is like imagination conjures but of
course great art is produced on the
shoulders of a lot of influence in the
past and one of the measures in an
English literature course of whether a
poem Rises to the level of worthiness to
be studied at University is the degree
of impact it had afterwards and that can
sometimes be measured by how many
imitators it generated so one thing I
always find fascinating is you read 14th
century literature and Chaucer stands
out as the main poet right if you barely
read any 15th century literature in an
English Lit course or at least when I
was in school in the 90s that was the
case I've just gone all blurry haven't I
I'm gonna see what's going on with my
camera here
um there we go refocused the camera has
its own priors
um so uh you know like Chaucer shut down
English literature for like a hundred
years and when I was when I was in an
English lyric survey course I'm like why
do we read Chaucer in the 14th century
and the next Port we read is the 16th
century what happened to the 15th
century and my professors were like well
every poet that wrote poetry in the 15th
century was seen as so much of a Chaucer
knockoff and derivative because his
style was so influential that none of
them rise to the level of having
contributed anything distinctive until
over 100 years later I was like wow now
that is impact right that is like as
much impact as you but ironically it's
like negative impact like the most
significant poem shuts everybody up
because they don't dare to do anything
except for imitated in a totally
derivative way but creating something
new out of it you know that's what is
creates the most fecundity in art right
like you create something and a lot of
her people were like oh I love this I'm
going to take it and adapt it run with
it that's one of the things I love about
hip-hop is it's so much about sampling
and flipping and remixing and it's not
afraid of any other genre because its
attitude is you can take any genre and
make it better by adding beats and
Rhymes uh but but really effective art
shuts it down I think Andrew Marvel was
also known as like the last Carpe Diem
poem writer because he wrote Such a
perfect Carpe Diem poem Gather ye
rosebuds while you may that no one
really bothered with that genre anymore
because nobody could do as well as
Andrew Marvel and he wrote the last
great Garden poem as well English garden
poem and it's like you know how do you
measure your success as an artist by the
degree to which you've created something
that's so intimidating for everybody
else that they don't even bother with
the genre anymore and now you're
measuring your success by the deletion
of genres from the cultural milieu which
creates space for other people to invent
more genres but this is an interesting
way to measure success
wow
I'm gonna pick up on that pattern and
bring it into attention and the Bayesian
perspective on attention which is
sometimes equated with precision
so if we're paying a lot of attention to
a sensory input
a lot of attention High Precision we're
really putting a lot of credence in that
information it's overriding our priors a
lot we're updating our beliefs to
basically be what we're paying attention
to
and then the other case would be we're
not paying attention we have low
Precision or high uncertainty and we're
not updating our beliefs at all that's
what we basically conversationally mean
when we say we're not paying attention
to that like I couldn't tell you what it
was it didn't leave an impact
and when you were talking about this
cultural evolutionary process I thought
about cultures paying attention to
genres and works because if there was
one work that was the object of
attention
it would be in the spotlight but
attention is like a spotlight and if
it's a laser on one thing it's not on
everything else
and if there's no work that's rising to
attention
then there's this proliferation of
hypotheses cultural endeavors
but no one of them will necessarily be
shared and so art that resonates with
communities and with your friends it's
like in this gray Zone where it has to
have enough attention on it so that
there can be a culture
of hip-hop or the Grateful Dead or
whatever it may be
but
not one that is so attended to
that it
gets burnt by the laser
yeah it's like if everyone's only paying
attention to one thing then that's
actually very stifling for cultural
flourishing because it's you know you
don't you don't get all the variance you
get these like totally dominant moments
you can see that at the macro level in
history but it also just happens in
social media all the time too right
everybody's talking about one thing and
then it's like
you know what what if that thing is not
interesting to you or you know
what that what is the upshot of that com
of that dominance of attention
in active inference we sometimes talk
about regimes of attention and there
have been some great recent papers on
cultural regimes of attention and that
kind of takes that basal Bayesian idea
of attention as Precision to stimuli
and it puts it into the dynamical space
where the regime of attention might be
like the sequence of eye cicades across
a page so that is a complex pattern with
attention moving and we could just call
that broadly like a regime of attention
or attention and action
and
in some sense that's what culture is or
can be described as as regime just the
kind of summary of where you happen to
look or is the intent that it's like
there is some kind of intentional
control of attention that is inherent to
the work that's being attended to like
you can expect people to look others in
the eyes when you're seeing a video or a
photo in the regime is that like there
must be some implied like uh maybe in
inbuilt psychology of things that we
tend to find more fascinating is that is
that what's implied by it or
a whole lot there the word regime does
have a slight connotation of something
that's imposed
whereas it is in the neutral sense
describing merely the Dynamics and then
what those shared regimes of attention
might be
like we're going to approach each other
this way making this kind of eye contact
and make these kinds of gestures that's
how we're going to be reducing our
uncertainty about who we are and what
this event is
and without those shibboleths
secret words and implicit or explicit
processes and rituals it's hard to lock
on culturally
and
there's so many ways to go from there
but I'll leave it yeah I'm always
whenever I see shiblets and Norms being
acted out I'm always trying to I mean
obviously there's scientific studies
that are trying to unpack this as well
but my favorite thing to speculate about
is to what degree is this culturally
constructed in an open-ended way and to
what degree is the cultural aspects of
it uh relying on an underlying cognitive
psychology that is inherited From
Evolution like for instance you know if
you're having a conversation with
somebody one-on-one and you never look
them in the eyes
you know you that's inherently
suspicious right like what's wrong with
this person they won't look me in the
eyes are they lying to me do they have
something to hide like that response
that you get emotionally and in terms of
like somebody's disposition towards you
you I would find that very unlikely to
be 100 culturally constructed like could
you imagine a society that was
egalitarian where they never looked each
other in the eyes I can imagine
societies were Aristocrats prohibit uh
people below them in the hierarchy from
looking in the eyes because it's seen as
a sign of disrespect which of course is
entirely based on primate behavior when
you're like challenging an alpha if you
look at them for too long then they'll
bite you and you gotta like cast your
eyes down to demonstrate your
submissiveness or whatever like humans
have replicated some of these very deep
mammalian instincts that we have right
but like are we malleable enough that a
society could ever evolve with the norm
of nobody ever looks the other person in
the eyes or would that street swim
upstream so strongly against our
instinctive ways of measuring our
degrees of trust and Affinity towards
each other that that culture would just
inherently fail and and not manage to be
represented in the panoply of cultures
going forward
I'll try to give a thought on that
falling back to this attention
discussion so the movement of the eyes
does provide information
whether it's deceptive or not it is an
outlet of information from the person
who you could be looking at so it's
putting attention itself right where you
look to find out if someone's paying
attention
the eyes are the window to the soul
maybe that wasn't just about the cornea
attention as the window to the soul
it was about Game Theory
and so to neglect this Fountain of
information
you have to have a cultural clamp on it
like a secondary reason to not look
because it is providing so much info on
a millisecond by millisecond level in
ways that aren't always even expressible
like pupil diameter has a lot to do with
arousal and psychologically people may
or may not know about that empirically
and I doubt it was shown empirically
until we had cameras and measuring
devices and millimeters and all of that
but it can still play a role implicitly
in behaviors and heuristics and
strategies and so it's like if we're
paying attention to our embodiment
certain things will arise
and
in situations where the inherited prior
has to overrule or reinterpret those
first principles takes
those are like scenarios with an
attention to the Past
for better and worse
that is shading
our experience interpretation
versus the Prima fascia situational
awareness that convergently evolves to a
few attractors like looking at
informative sources of information
yeah and and just because there's a lot
of uh swimming Upstream of uh sort of
instinctive cognition necessary for uh
cultural norms to play out doesn't
necessarily mean that they're doomed to
fail or you know a waste of time or
whatever you could almost say like the
whole scientific Enterprise complex
mathematics even reading none of these
things are you know instinctively
evolved they're all very recent and
we're like building them on top of our
uh older cognition and and architecture
and instincts but they're you know
gloriously culturally constructed and I
would say like worthy of uh the effort
of swimming Upstream
the keyboard
q-w-e-r-t-y oh well the keyboard doesn't
have to be that way well yeah but we
don't need keyboards and we haven't
always had them and we won't always have
them and left to right reading it could
be right to left or up to down or it
could be any but we haven't even had
inscription technology
so maybe let me bring it back to your
experience with hip-hop how has the
generative process the extended
cognitive niche of Technology
supported the remix culture and how does
that manifest
well I think I'll start with some of the
good ones I used to go to a studio and
sit with producers and hear their beats
and uh you know like let's go with that
one and then like Try lyric side
pre-written or sometimes write the track
um it was really expensive
fun interactively I I do miss the
in-person studio experience but all the
previous rap records I've made for the
past 10 years were all made remotely
with Dropbox so the rappers you know
send or the producers send me a folder
full of Beats I choose the one that I
like the best I write the rap I record
the wraps at home I send them to the
producer and I've got like a track where
the producers based in Seattle the uh
session musician is playing Keys is in
Vancouver the vocalist is doing the song
uh you know from his place in Toronto
and I'm in Long Island like taking all
the different parts and editing them and
then sending them to the mix engineer
and the master you know it's like this
great distributed collaborative process
and you know that's even by today's
standard that's analog right that's like
sharing files in a Dropbox and throwing
them into your local studio
and and sort of like
measuring each input against the
expectation
a song to sound ultimately and giving
people feedback and asking for revisions
uh but I think there are now ai uh sort
of web 3 platforms where you can all be
in the same virtual room and the
latencies worked out in your
collaborating musically I haven't used
those yet but I've been uh you know I've
been scoping them out so that's been a
very I think that's generally been
positive it's brought the cost down and
it's allowed for real time well not
quite real time but like ongoing
collaboration with creatives across
different areas uh but then the kind of
parallel Revolution that's happened is
from selling CDs uh selling tape selling
CDs and then Spotify takes over and
you're getting like fractions of pennies
on the stream and your music is going
into this massive Archive of every kind
of music and you're only getting paid
based on how much your music is listened
to compared to every other music that's
on there they're partitioning their
subscription fees and it's really it's
become much harder uh I think for a lot
of musicians to make a living from the
sale of music and so over the past 10 to
15 years that process really pushed a
lot of artists into really just basing
all their income on live performance
like setup gigs and and Rock shows and
sell Merchant shows if you want any
expectation of income from music sales
you better be there meeting the fan
shaking their hand and sending them a CD
in person then kovid shut that down you
know for a couple of years anyway it's
coming back but my estimation during the
pandemic was even as it comes back it's
gonna you know there's gonna be people
that are more reluctant to travel to
shows and you know do that have the
in-person experience even when Public
Health notices say it's safe because
people have different degrees of
paranoia and anxiety and they won't feel
as comfortable even if it is objectively
safe uh so you know pivoting to
this uh event rap game was partially
based on an analysis of what's happening
with the industry and how hard it is to
make it as an artist and part of that
has been uh you know a technology driven
process
wow also many ways to go
let's kind of return to those
expectations
and I think there'll be some
ways that your experience with
expectations
my map or resonate to the Bayesian brain
so
say a little bit about what are your
expectations when you're coming out
to a performance
whatever setting that you choose to
think about and then how does that
interface with or to what extent do you
even
preempt or pre-game the audience's
expectation do you just
call it like you see it or are you
looking to finesse your performance
based upon what you rightly or wrongly
believe their expectations to be
well there's an ambient uh
characteristic that I kind of just take
for granted which is that I'm not very
famous but I have you know a core
hardcore Boutique fan base of the like
science rap science nerds and science
rap nerds that so if I'm in front of a
crowd most of the time
more than half of them don't even know
who I am and I've got to introduce
myself to them for the first time and
some portion of them have seen a bunch
of my shows and their fans and they're
like oh it's his next show you know but
I don't really write to uh address an
audience that knows me generally and my
assumption is that they don't and I'm
constantly reintroducing myself and
finding new fans that way and let's be
honest like you see me walking down the
street you're not going to be like there
goes a rapper you know the Bayesian
priors of my ability to perform as a
rapper are low and they have been since
I started I was as bookish you know
Suburban Canadian woodsy teenager like I
want to be a rapper but no one's gonna
believe I'm a rapper so I better get
really good at rapping and also you know
just it is a bit of a choice not to like
dress overtly to hip-hop or talk or
overtly to hip-hop it's like there is a
hip-hop Persona that a lot of artists
adopt maybe becomes natural to them and
they could say this is who I am there
was either a conscious or unconscious
decision at some point in their growth
where they you know became more
seemingly hip-hop maybe to reduce the
cognitive dissonance of the lack of uh
you know expectations of them being able
to rap from Their audience maybe for
other reasons maybe peer influence maybe
they just you know none of that analysis
really uh matters and they just they
felt it they were passionate so they
started adopting the lingo and you know
I I kind of uh always partitioned rap a
little bit like when I'm performing I'm
a rapper and my profession is I'm a
rapper but I'm not gonna like make
myself a cup of tea in a rap style you
know what I'm saying is like I I do
distinguish a little bit between the
domains of my life and uh what that
partially what that means is people
don't Mark me and expect me to be good
at it uh or to be able to deliver and
then I get to you know there's a cost
benefit there right for one thing like
the skepticism might lose me potential
opportunity entities to perform or
potential members of the audience who
like see me setting up the mic and
they're like that guy I don't think so
and then leave but on the other hand the
transformation I get to take an audience
through as they realize what they're
experiencing and and feel their uh
expectations being overturned is
actually I think really part of the joy
of the experience you know it's an
expectation shattering experience when
someone that you don't expect to be able
to deliver in a certain art form just
really does and uh and I and I kind of
play with that in the comedy and tease
the audience for having low expectations
of me and stuff like that
um you know then but then uh
part of this is contingent on me just
never getting that famous you know if if
there was a point at which I had
achieved as much as much of a fan base
as mm my like writing style about you
don't think I'm going to be able to rap
do you while watch this would of course
sound pointless kind of like he stopped
writing about being poor after his first
album and the first line of his second
album was they say I can't rap about
being broke no more you know just like
naming the critical uh reception of his
transition from album one to millionaire
album two uh so you know I think there
is a kind of interplay between artists
and their audiences and you know I I I
stay Niche and I write to the
expectations of that niche
we're all in our own Niche so I hope
that part doesn't change but very
interesting
when we attend
we don't even need to say pay attention
and use this economic modality but when
we attend to our experience
and update our priors
just statistically that's called
learning
and I think that speaks to this
synthesis with the language
the Lexicon the slang or as we might
call it the active inference ontology
speaks across a Continuum from the
experiential
and the folks psychological the
day-to-day
it's the same terms with the same
authentic relationships that are
increasingly becoming embodied in our
intelligence algorithms again not even
calling it artificial intelligence
algorithms because their extensions into
the niche from us so
these
cognitive models that are being deployed
AI artificial intelligence or large
language models
they are cognitive entities and they're
participating in these ecosystems of
engagements with us so
I uh
I had a conversation with the new
um chat GPT driven Bing engine last
night I just got I just got added to
Bing uh the the AI driven version it's
interesting the first thing I did when
chat GPT came out was I said write me a
rap song in the style of Snoop
that explains how to change the oil in a
Honda CRV
because that's exactly the kind of
project that we do with event wrap you
know event wrap is like a team of
skilled professional 10-year veteran
artists that'll make you a song on any
topic and either record it as a video
that you can share uh as a kind of
public engagement or explainer or come
in live to one of your events virtually
or in person and perform but it's like
top it's a topical rap agency it's like
all the rappers have their own catalogs
but they don't perform them at the
events we book they always create all
new stuff and uh chat gbt's Honda CRV
wrap oil change wrapping the style of
Snoop was like uncannily on point it was
very like it you know it had the like
Snoop Dogg
lingo it was like an accurate
description of the steps that you would
have to take uh to change the oil in
your CRV it was like a cogently you know
from a scripting perspective I felt like
we had a threat on our hands you know
like Chad gbt has definitely like shook
a lot of people's uh professions
marketing copy professors academics it's
writing papers like yeah it's you know
the economics of this thing have not
even begun to Dawn on people yet but the
question in my mind was how soon is it
coming for the rapper's job
and uh there was there was a
sophomoric cartoonish kind of
kindergarten flavor to the way it's
constructing bars uh you know so chat
gbt and and Bing uh by extension I think
it's the same uh uh layer that's running
it is
um you know it's it writes Raps like
someone who's never wrapped before so if
I told you write me a rap you could do
it but there's like layers of
proficiency of you know Master Level
stuff that that of like syncopation and
internal Rhythm within the main stresses
of the bars and especially and this is
where I was chatting about with Bing
last night is polysyllabic rhyme so
polysyllabic rhyme schemes are like the
construction of multi-syllable Rhymes
out of parts of other words and I was
like um uh asking Bing can you do
polysyllabic Rhymes and Bing was like
yes I can and I said okay give me some
examples from mainstream rap of
polysyllabic Rhymes and it pulled an
example from MF Doom which was is an
excellent example it was like
um you know the girls are crazy schizo
but she's got amazing tits though uh so
you know you can hear the pattern crazy
skitso amazing tits though it's like
multiple words constructing a longer
pattern of syllables I was like gravo
bing you found a perfect polysyllabic
Rhyme now write me a wrap that explains
your internal uh data architecture or
your algorithmic architecture in the
style of MF Doom emphasizing
polysyllabic Rhymes couldn't do it all
monosyllabic like check me out I'm being
I do a verse I am artificial
intelligence I don't even need to
rehearse and I was like bing those are
not polysyllabic Rhymes you started out
quoting MF Doom complex five syllable
rhyme pattern and now you're rhyming
rehearse with verse like don't insult my
intelligence and I was like dissing the
AI and then I was like I'm sorry I'm a
new model and I will get better at
polysyllabic Ryan but basically that is
the thing that's got our job safe for
now because if rap is an elite art form
that takes a decade or more to master
the techniques of flowing live
freestyling polysyllabic rhyme and
Rhythm patterns and also there's a
confidence to perform are the things
that we're still getting paid for even
if ability to write a basic like
competent rap is now easily achievable
by AIS
I'm sure even outside of the rap
profession these conversations are
happening they certainly are in research
and education
previously the artifacts that we exuded
into our Niche were mnemonic almost at
best it was probably transformative when
some of these oral Traditions were able
to be written down
and that may have also been seen as
threatening to the underlying
basis of the skill and the transmission
and now
we had just a brief window of these
inner
externalized artifacts these mnemonic
devices have only existed AKA writing
for however long they've been in the
niche
and now it's like
they've come
not quite to life but certainly to
activity
and now these off-sourced and outsourced
cognitive entities are not just
receiving and holding but doing
and that
transforms
who and what we are in terms of our
perception cognition and action loops
they're going to be different and that
is what any given particular thing is so
you mean like any any technological
innovation that changes how we interact
with each other and with our art forms
yeah and and from the technical side we
use the word thing in active inference
to describe the blanket and the internal
States
so we take a particular partition we
cleave off the thing we're talking about
from the environments the generative
model of the thing is the blanket and
the internal States and so that thing is
defined in terms of its perception
cognition internal States and action
so when new sensory modalities or sense
data appear when new action modalities
affordances
appear and when our thinking is
different it's a different thing
it isn't just like well we mixed this
one thing with another thing and they
both retain their identity it's like
there's been transformation and a
learning and
were in the middle of some fractal
dimension of it
yeah one of one of the uh I mean I think
this is like a radical break from from
previous technological changes you know
one of the things I argued in my thesis
um when I was a master's student was
that poets conceived of Their audience
and their ability to connect with people
orally primarily in Chaucer's time right
reciting your poetry for a listening
crowd but then the invention of the
printing press with Gutenberg changed
that ability to imagine an audience
because it was so much easier to imagine
our silent readership of 10 000 people
reading your pamphlet but making ten
thousand Vellum manuscripts by hand was
always prohibitively expensive so no
poet could even imagine ever having a
fan base through text right Gutenberg
allows for the possibility of a fan base
through text which changes the whole art
form suddenly rhyme is extraneous
because they're going to be reading
quietly anyway so who cares what the
Poetry sounds like the main thing should
be carefully constructed syntax and
story in semantics in a concentrated way
but you see then this rise of free verse
right Shorty's poetry is sort of like
shorn of all of its ornaments and my
hypothesis was that they were just
basically irrelevant because people were
reading quietly and not reciting out
loud and then uh Edison invents recorded
sound which creates the possibility of
an audience and fan base that's just as
vast from the sound of your words as it
would be from the silent readership and
that paves the way for the possibility
of hip-hop and because this is like
people that are writing things rhyming
verse and of course I call this the
rhyme Renaissance right poetry was all
rhymed then none of it was rhymed and
then if you think of rap as poetry now
it's all rhymed again because who cares
about poetry rap dominates like all of
our verse consumption compared to every
other kind of poetry out there right and
rap is rhymed and I think people
instinctively resonate with rhyme and
just took a break from it when they were
reading silent pamphlets published by
Poets who were imagining their
readership but each of these examples is
like a technological innovation that
mediates the creative process with its
ability to connect with an audience but
this AI thing is something completely
different isn't it it's like competing
with us for it's a in our production of
the creative things and right now I'm
taking some comfort in the fact that
it's competing ineptly it's not as good
at writing a rap as a good rapper but
you know I'm probably a subset of
professions that can still say that and
lots I mean it's passing the LSAT it's
passing the um all the Masters entry
exams and you know which which rarified
skill sets will be left maybe I could
comfort myself to say the rapper will be
the last to fall to AI because of the
combination of creativity and semantic
cogency and humor and all the things
that go into it that the AI is going to
have to work each of those out like
maybe stand-up comics too uh are safe
for a while because GPT can write some
jokes but they're corny jokes still
right like original jokes it writes
aren't that good compared to you know a
Dave Chappelle so but but what are we
talking like 10 years of safe jobs uh as
artists or less you know like the speed
of this last six months has been a
little mind-blowing
who is the deep blue who is the Gary
Kasparov of performance what is the
Turing test and for you to again calling
back the real recognized real
I listen to that as being like kind of a
Turing test
is you have cognitive entities in this
moment of reflection which has been
called theory of mind and in active
inference sometimes is called thinking
through other Minds ttom because there's
this cognitive emulation of if I do this
then they'll do that
and so thinking through other Minds
used to be a defined
set of types of Minds we had children we
had adults like us we had adults in
different cultures we had squirrels
and then
the workshop is open and the
composability is Extreme especially with
algorithms that can construct other
algorithms
and all of a sudden that ecosystem of
shared intelligence thinking through
other Minds we don't even know if it's a
sports car or a horse and buggy or a
spaceship and someone's like do you want
to get in
and it's like where are we going what is
it going to be like all those
expectations that we might want to have
about a journey
and an event
and who can say what
with any Precision things will be like
so what do we do then
yeah except it's more like a spaceship
that people that the pilot is like do
you want to get in if you don't all
these people are gonna die uh and so you
know it's it's your choice whether you
want to get in but your lives on the
line because obviously people that work
in all kinds of medical fields and
scientific Fields will Point directly to
the amount of human suffering that
they're on the verge of alleviating
using these tools and the applications
to wrap our job stealing are merely you
know side effects spandrels of the main
focus of it which is I think mostly very
laudable and very necessary right like
this like let's not get on the spaceship
means you know we continue to put up
with all kinds of genetic diseases and
you know levels of poverty and public
health crises and things like that that
are being that the AI is being applied
to and is likely to do a great job in
solving
yeah someone says look if your
four-year-old still wants to do art by
hand
we don't need to stop that but we just
want to use it here
that's going to be something that's very
challenging to take a long-term
perspective on
because it's going to seem like a
reasonable compromise in the moment just
like everything always does
and what compromise was made when those
oral Traditions were written down
what compromise was made when that sheet
music became recorded and that became
canonical and distributed and so what is
the nature of the compromise
and who's at the table
in 2023
yeah that that I think that's exactly
the right level of analysis and uh you
can say on balance that each of the
compromises we made for some new
technology to you know give us some cost
but also benefits it was a totally
understandable and reasonable one uh you
know from the perspective of like when I
look at an individual poet giving up on
rhyme because they want to do pamphlets
and reach more people I'm like well they
got a family to feed you know that's the
way that they can achieve the notoriety
and the a claim that is their path to
success as an individual and it has
cultural ramifications overall and that
you know that's I think you can put that
like people can opt out of any
technology and the people that decide to
opt in have totally defensible personal
choice reasons for why they're doing so
usually to get a competitive advantage
that was the case with you know tools
going back to the Stone Age right I only
throw rocks I don't use bow and arrows
all right you do you I'm a take down
this Antelope over here uh you know
we'll give you a piece if you're lucky
uh you know that's just that's that's
the AI tool choice that everyone's
facing right now too
it also makes me think about art
always playing this role of like the tip
of the spear that kind of penetrates the
Veil we had the discussion about nfts as
if they were just a question about art
but of course digital certificates are a
lot broader and more significant than
just visual images and there's a
discussion about whether certain kinds
of art are being replaced by generative
algorithms long ago six months ago 12
months ago when it was pre-chat GPT but
there was a lot of the stable diffusion
and midi Journey type algorithms then
the conversation was more about
graphical design and professionals but
of course that is a broader discussion
that isn't just about the generation of
images that you are paying a creative
professional to make and it's like art
as this
Frontier
and mediator with the open-ended
will people be looking for
open-endedness and liminality in their
events in 50 years I think they will be
that
niche the marginal niche of Art
as well as the central role of Art
I think it's fair to say we'll both
exist now whether that cultural
attention on the central artifacts will
be
about
artifacts made by a person an algorithm
or something in between you know if
somebody designs a 3D sculpture but then
it's printed or if they think about a
drawing and then they use a pen that was
produced by a machine
who's to say in these extended scenarios
whether one or the other made it but in
the margins
it's where we're always going to be
exploring in whatever people call Art
and people who are in the middle of the
spotlight saying that's not art it's not
their art
but
every single genre
has had to have this mitosis or birthing
process
with people who weren't part of that
process saying it wasn't art or that's
not the right way to do this kind of
science or rap is not music
you know that as a hip-hop partisan I'm
very familiar with uh defending against
the rarefied tastes of people that want
to gatekeep what constitutes art and
what doesn't but um you know one thing
I've always loved about rap that like
that that aspect of it not being
gatekeep by elitists you know like if
you want to be a professional ballet
dancer you know like Billy Elliot
stories notwithstanding you got to try
to get into Juilliard and have you have
to go through the process of rarified
Judges that are telling people who can
and can't get into the next one Lake
like there is no back door to success in
some art forms right classical music
Opera but then but with hip-hop there's
no front door to success it's like you
got to get good at it on the street
level there's no degree that'll get you
a job in it you just have to find crowds
and entertain them uh at the level of
your neighborhood and then your city and
then your state and and if you're you
know if you survive the levels of
competition on the way up then you get
to the you know the war World stage or
whatever but it's very like you know
pick up a mic and show what you got kind
of thing and it's mediated by the
audience and the fans uh you know if
they like it it's right and if they
don't like it is wrong and MC has moved
the crowd and you know there's a fairly
like
definitive objective measurement about
whether someone's doing rap well or not
and is how the crowd is responding
there's no valid argument that
everybody's booing you but you're
actually awesome because they just don't
understand your art no you failed to
understand the context in which your art
was meant to be consumed right so
whenever we're looking at these
trade-offs often it comes down to
producers and consumers right each new
tool is good for consumers but bad for
producers and this is like the taxi
guilds trying to fight off Uber Uber is
great for people that want to ride but
it's bad for people that are going to
try to control the means of production
and you're seeing this exact process
play out with chat GPT now which is like
you know and and also with stable
diffusion and the other examples you
gave like people want to consume art and
they don't necessarily care who made it
as long as their reception of it gives
them the feelings that they want from
the consumption right and that I think
that's the case with music and with
poetry as well although we're not yet
consuming a ton of AI generated music
and poetry and comedy because it's not
sophisticated enough to produce the
highest level stuff although I think
with classical music it is and with
graphic design and art it is right like
the best AI art is actually competitive
commercially or you know from a consumer
perspective you know like taste test
wise with the best rarefied
professionals which is devastating for
them but it's not unique it's been you
know that's what the guilds have wanted
to do for centuries is protect their
status as the elite producers of a thing
from the ability of just about anybody
to consume it for as cheaply as they
want and that's what technology keeps
delivering and in general I'm actually a
fan of that process I think it's
democratizing it's good for everybody on
average even though it perpetually
upends the guilds but we shouldn't give
guilds control over our ability to
consume excellence and if if Excellence
is delivered better by AIS then let's
not be curmudgeons about that and I can
actually you know but but there is still
an individual challenge like okay what
am I going to do to make a living now
you know it does really create a lot of
potential unemployment and economic
Devastation which is why a lot of people
have thought that there's just no Escape
From The Universal basic income because
the jobs are going to fall and Society
will descend into chaos with that much
unemployment and frustration and
resentment and anger but you know even
if rappers are the last job to fall
you know the analysis has to apply to
all kinds of other jobs first and uh
active inference comes into this because
you know how does a rapper entertain the
crowd by having a mental model of what
the crowd's going to do if they perform
action X right what it will be the
effect of X on y why is the crowd X is
the intervention and the intervention is
a choice of a bar I'm going to rhyme
this with this I'm going to make a song
about this topic I'm going to try this
joke out in my flow as a punchline and
you have a mental model oh yeah people
are going to think that's really funny
you know and then you deploy it and
you'd see the degree to which your
expectation has been fulfilled and I
don't think AI is that good at that yet
because it doesn't model expectations of
audiences very well yet does it it
doesn't have deep theories of Mind of
like perceptions of perceptions of
perceptions it just has averaging
abilities to recreate patterns that it
finds in vastroves of human created art
which includes pixel patterns and
graphics and and patterns and text
romantic and syntactic patterns but like
performance art with an audience
requires a mental prior of the
audience's disposition and attitude and
that that's why I say rap's going to be
the last to fall but and that's also why
it's really hard to get good at you know
it takes years of Performing dying on
stage and sucking and being booed before
you really build up this mental model of
like I know what people like and I know
if I do this they'll do that and even
I've been doing this for 25 years I'm
wrong all the time oh yeah that line
fell flat all good all good you know
either you like carry on or you go fix
it that's where the AI That's where the
AIS have to get to right
yeah
wow so much
one thought was rap will be the last of
fall in the first to rise
around that campfire again it'll arise
situationally
you mean after Society descends into
chaos and all the AIS are resting and
we're back to Spears rap will be the
first to arise again
first in last out
sorry go ahead what was the next thing
another thought you mentioned taste
makers
and uh I thought what is the ultimate or
even the proximate taste maker it's our
generative model of taste it's every
person eating that dish The Taste maker
isn't who told them to go to the
restaurant that's basically believing
the hype and using the Paradigm of the
advertising industry The Taste maker is
the taster that's who is generating the
experience of taste taste isn't just in
the dish before it is actually
eaten by that person it's experienced
and they're going to have
some previous taste in their mouth or
they're going to have a context or a
cultural understanding or a memory a
trigger so the taste is generated
authentically and situationally
and
yeah there's going to be a lot of
volatility
as taste making becomes
actually understood to be personalized
and that that may look like the personal
generation of media which has not even
been plausible
when you had only 33 RPM records then
you have somebody selecting which ones
to distribute but
when you have algorithms it takes it one
level further which ones you like to
listen to people who like this also
listen to that and this is like as far
as we can see another level of like you
liked this we're gonna regenerate that
story so that the person's voice is like
that that takes it to the next level but
also
with enormous
trade-offs
it brings it closer to how things really
are
well that that makes me think of
something we spoke on earlier which is
the degree to which cultural norms are
able to reorganize or swim upstream
against instincts right so when you say
the tastemaker is the taster uh the
counter examples that jump to mind are
rappers who are like Jay-Z where he's
like and before this song ends I'ma
start another Trend you know like if you
want to say the tasters of The Taste
makers I'm looking at people who merely
suggest something is cool and it
instantly becomes cool and everybody is
able to post hoc rationalize reasons why
it has intrinsic qualities that they now
recognize as amazing over and above what
the taste maker told them to do but we
are highly susceptible primates uh to
cool factors and you know so I would
suggest The Taste maker is not the
taster The Taste maker is the best
predictor of the average response of the
tasters and when you get very very good
at understanding instinctively how
people will react to The Taste using
taste as a metaphor for all kinds of art
then you're able to be treated as
authoritative on taste because you're
right so often about what people will
like and that power of like vested
expertise from your fan base then allows
you to start trends that are not just
predictive you say something's great and
everybody instantly believes it's great
and experiences it is great as
authentically as if they had discovered
it for themselves and decided it was
great because they've recognized your
actual real vertical average ability to
predict taste across groups
awesome I I thought okay again who's the
taste maker it's the chef
and not everyone's in the kitchen
because a chef is in their position
because they've been recognized to
repeatedly be able to construct dishes
that in the local taste making diners
like
or maybe just a few diners like and it's
like what you can't do that with
Molecular Gastronomy but some so it's
like it's the chef and it's the social
influence Network and it's local
what framework can we use to think about
all of these interactions within and
among cognitive entities
within and among their niche
we use active inference as just a way of
thinking about it well what is active
inference it's there in the title action
and inference
it's involving action and doing
cognitive modeling
and that gives us the composability and
the ability to reconfigure and remix
to capture all of these diverse
scenarios not to close the book on them
but to be like oh wow what an amazing
question there's 50 phds of research
that you could go into
so it's a question generator and it's a
lens by people who are even just
beginning to learn it who review
phenomena that they've already
been told or experienced in one light
all of a sudden they're seeing how it
can be reconfigured for example seeing
what we prefer in terms of what we
expect rather than what we prefer in
terms of what's rewarding which is the
reward learning reinforcement Paradigm
which proposes well maybe you know the
value of different states and you're
maximizing value
it resonates with some
contrast that with you have this complex
generative model and you're always
referencing to it and you're taking
actions and learning to reduce your
surprise bound your surprise of certain
kinds which could include increasing
your narrative surprise and you want
that page Turner or the horror film
so it just kind of
reflects back and then one last point on
octave inference as a research direction
that the university you hear your
thoughts on is it is happening
in a Time
that has never been seen before in
research and Academia so you said
there's certain careers
um or genres where there's no back door
to success and then you said in rap
there's no front door so
traditionally even if we could say there
was no backdoor to success in research
the reality is there was a side door and
people were getting kicked out and being
brought into the party through the side
door and a bunch of people were waiting
at the front door they didn't even know
that the show was not happening that way
were developing a framework
in community at the speed of pre-prints
and live streams and so there's
transdisciplinary collaborations with
philosophy historians of science
cognitive researchers mathematicians
physicists so there's a
transdisciplinary conversation and one
with practitioners and one that's
happening with everybody
with view access to some large parts of
it which wasn't even the case previously
open science and research was like break
down the paywalls everybody should have
access to the PDFs which is great but it
turns out that having access to 200 000
PDFs having access to every single PDF
that Carl friston has ever been an
author on
it's not even going to take you 10
percent of the way
unless you're gonna engage in this total
monastic life to unpack them and the
details aren't even in
what's necessarily those papers it's
beyond that it's in the community it's
in the software in the inaction so
of course
wait and see but there's so much with
the way that active inference is
developing on the influence of previous
Frameworks Bayesian brain and Bayesian
statistics causal inference
statistical physics
happening in this sort of
wrapping in front of the crowd way
asynchronously with the pre-prints
synchronously with remote presentations
and recordings
that it's hard to think of another area
that has had that kind of a
developmental niche
you're saying active inference is the
hip-hop of the scientific Community
basically
you said it not me live on the mic I
love it yeah and it's uh you know I I
think it's super exciting research and
collaboration happening and it's I mean
it's very very unknown to the public you
know if you try to explain what this
conversation is about uh you know people
understand the idea of expectation and
priors and belief upgrading the very
sort of basic version of of the Bayesian
algorithm but
um you know all the applications of it
and the cross-disciplinary side and
everything you know it needs more
science communication I've made two
Bayesian songs I want I think I need to
make 20 more because this is uh you know
the the applications of the research are
vast and especially you know in the AI
era like people really need to know what
these algorithms are achieving and the
ways in which they are similar or
different to our own cognitive processes
and what we can expect them to achieve
uh and how we can expect them to help
and what they're threatening all that
stuff goes through active inference
doesn't it
awesome well in our kind of closing
segments would you like to do something
musical or how do you want to proceed
yes indeed I'd love to I'm uh I'm very
happy to do a demonstration of one of
the last art forms that AI is not yet
able to model and that is a freestyle
rap so uh if we have anybody watching on
the stream or Daniel you're welcome to
do it as well if you want to pop some
phrases into the uh the text I will look
at the text on uh that you're displaying
and also look at the uh the comments and
the Chats on YouTube and anything that I
see pop up I will visually uh process
and convert into Rhymes in a freestyle
rap track and uh you know just just to
give a little insight into into this
this process you know it's like um it it
is a violation and uh and like uh
expectation setting and expectation
violating process right like the the
active listener to a freestyle rap is
trying to figure out the semantics and
figure out where the wrap's gonna go and
the wrapper is also in real time
figuring out the semantics because it's
completely unscripted but it's uh you
know then and and at the same trying
trying to set up expectations of the
audience and violate them I think a lot
of the fun is the surprise factor of
like oh I didn't expect him to go there
I thought he was going to go there but
oh now I see and like it's kind of like
a game of Chase like the rabbit and the
fox uh so I see Sean Kelly's uh drop
topology in the in the uh chat of
YouTube I'm gonna start there and I'm
gonna kick a little rap for you guys
yeah
yo
this is hip-hop tell me what you think
this is is Bubba Brinkmann rocking now
on active inference that's the inference
looking for where info is I don't know
but I feel it's kind of intimate yes
indeed hip-hop what you think this is is
Bubba Brinkman here on the active
inference podcast I'm looking for where
the info is so I could update my priors
and get into it and maybe drop a beat
Sean Kelly said topology yes right now
I'm rocking hip hop ology can't you even
see that's how I adjust the bass and
treble topology that means checking all
the levels and looking for the map and
the different levels of impact I'm
spitting rap yes I'm looking at the jet
that's how I kick it yes how I go with
rap and flows it is me kicking it with
Mr Daniel Friedman house speaking yes
I'm always just deleting variants every
time I'm sometimes just weekend through
the speakers I just do this on a Tuesday
or a week and indeed active inferences
how I'm speaking I'm sneaking past all
your expectations like a rat and a maze
because my raps will amaze and yes I'm
doing Holly syllabic too amazed I'm just
having to blaze yes I'm actively playing
all the different rhymes on my brain
like a piano changing the channels like
I'm rocking gangster Tony Soprano yeah
that's okay this is how I just anger the
listeners sometimes cause raps are
danger gotta give a shout out to Tucker
Cahill Chambers who rock this with us
yes Working The Angles like bass theorem
can you even hear them when I'm Nero and
I start to see it as this Mass
scientific theorem that I could apply to
every single single thing as Barbara
Brinkman gets all your neurons jingling
it's how I attacked it I attracted a
massive I'm active when I'm doing
inference in my rap and indeed this is
how I kick it when I enter my rap is
directed it's never non-censored as I
just try to constructed mistakes I make
sometimes I'm Run DMC and sometimes I'm
Drake except I'm not quite as good of a
singer with The Melodies but then again
I've got the freeze thieves that kick a
lot of active inference Bayesian Styles
freestyles that's trying to make the
people smile less they're listening yes
that's how I'm straight rocking even a
mod mostafi says yo wow awesome with
explosion emojis Baba Brinkman coming
with the dope beats people are like
hopefully he's one of those MC's that
could Rock straight up as ancient
hip-hop like Rakim and Eric B I never do
it terribly I just free style that is
improv which means it's spontaneous my
style is the Zanies I'm repping for the
long Islanders plus the Canadians people
listen and blow their brains when I'm
blazing it yeah it's how it goes when
I'm speaking on the basics I'm in Long
Island but Daniel he's up in Davis
California I put it on you it's active
inference Bubba Brickman when I'm
speaking it I'm getting into it looking
for where the info is that's how I'm
rocking this was like a four minute
continuous talk and demonstration yes
indeed I'll make it easy let's see you
do this [__] chat gpt3 you can't do it
you can't freestyle over this music and
use a brain to actively infer that's so
fluid yes that's a wrap that I make up
and invent the last four minutes has
been an event prescribed in the time
that's the freestyle rap that I did on
this concept that's how I can adapt yes
indeed that's a rhyme that I had to make
I can do this my brain makes me a
primate but I don't make mistakes okay
sometimes I do but that's just mutation
yes that's how I move all the mistakes
get integrated my work is huge thank you
Ahmad mustafi I appreciate you okay now
I'm starting to wind down and trying to
just find a new direction for the rhyme
sound this is how I just get into it
it's Baba Brinkman rocking with active
inference Act give inference this is how
I'm never pretending I'm trying to infer
some way for the raps ending but wait a
second this is how I do it hip-hop the
easiest solution is just turn the music
off
foreign
that's freestyle rap and I really
appreciated this shot chat it was a ton
of fun and super interesting
I'll give a closing remark and then any
last words from you
it brought a smile and a laugh to my
face and body because another individual
was engaging in the shared moments I've
seen language models output incredible X
in the style of Y and every single time
it brings a chuckle or less and it's
like okay I kind of expected it to do
that I want and um I'm disappointed if
it can't fulfill my request because it's
like well I expected I would I asked you
this because I expected you to do that
when there's joyful spontaneous
engagements
that
is reflective of a shared experience
it's the real thing
and when
that lens is applied
it's going to be real recognizing real
and I don't think humans will be out of
a relationship role for each other
for a long long time
Amen to that and um I just want to say
that the phrase that you just coined uh
joyful spontaneous experience that's
reflect or joyful spontaneous uh
engagement that's reflective of a shared
experience uh that is basically the
entire value proposition of my event
wrap company is find a topic or an event
or something that creates Collective
attention of a group and have that be
the locus and the Catalyst of a wrap
because you know the the rap game is
entirely predicated on make a thing that
is very very widely appreciated and goes
viral and is hugely massive and you know
making general purpose art is what most
rappers rappers are focusing on and I
really thought it would be interesting
to apply a rapper skill to this uh
joyful shared experience and spontaneity
Challenge and uh you know thank you for
giving me a platform for it and I hope
your audience will now imagine in every
other possible application of a shared
experience that a rapper could add value
to because uh if such things occur then
my business will succeed and lots of
rappers will get lots of gigs rapping in
weird places like this and I think that
would add to the joyful variety of the
world and the genre
amazing so thank you so much Baba always
welcome to come back give us updates
when that rap guide to active inference
drops
all right I'm on it I'm on it thank you
thanks Daniel peace peace